you got this yeah me in the ring you got
rules I'd say you got nothing
life history with all these cheap shots
people like me living fast you got
people that you need you know you got
everything to loose
this guy's got nothing in loose I got a
choice
that's to say that your father said and
he died right here in my hands this with
me this guy is dangerous
I don't think I can beat I was afraid I
couldn't live up to these expectations
you don't think you got your validation
I want to rewrite history don't pretend
this is about your father
it may not seem like it now but this is
more than just fight
my DNA hey everybody its charlie time to
get rekt they dropped the Creed to trail
if you didn't know they made a sequel to
that movie kill monger to however you
want to think about it he just blew up
since Black Panther became one of the
biggest movies of all time let alone
superhero movies and probably one of the
best villains that Marvel has ever done
but if you're finding me for the first
time be sure to subscribe to get all the
videos there's a whole bunch of stuff
that just happened today especially in
the Marvel Universe so I'll explain that
at the end of the video because I do
have stuff planned for later but most of
you probably spotted the Drago warm-ups
in this maybe you heard a little bit
about the conception of the movie when
they were talking about it a long time
ago because black panther director Ryan
Coogler got black panther because of
what he's in with Creed he doesn't some
other cool movies too with Michael B
Jordan but Creed was him proving that he
could do a really big blockbuster movie
he didn't come back to direct this
sequel he's still busy trying to get a
deal locked down with Marvel for Black
Panther 2 so aside from that for the
most part pretty much the same team that
did the first Creed film but as you can
see they sort of pick up at the end of
the last movie and they're incorporating
some elements from Rocky 3 like when
he'd actually started to rise to the top
he got a little complacent clubber Lang
mr. t came around I pity the fool and he
became the underdog that rocky was in
the previous films so now
Adonis is no longer the underdog he
proves that he's a badass they haven't
said how much time has passed but they
just imply that like now he's on the
scene he's actually earning some money
doing well it looks like he now has a
baby with Tessa Thompson's character
remember her big thing in the first film
was is that she loved music but she was
losing the ability to hear slowly it
looks like that just continues during
this so like she has her own side plot
going on but the main thing here I think
isn't so much Adonis proving that he's a
badass by just accepting every challenge
that comes his way it's more about
getting revenge for the death of his
father because they have you know the
rocky 4 element because Drago killed his
father at the beginning of that film
that was the big call to action for
Rocky ok I'm gonna go to the Soviet
Union and kick this dude's ass and even
though you don't see him in the trailer
Dolph Lundgren is in the sequel I don't
know if he has a hand in training his
son his son's name is Victor his son
wants to get revenge for his disgraced
father
the raki match when they were in the
Soviet Union so you have two people that
are trying to avenge their respective
fathers so they're trying to balance it
a little bit more it's not so much good
versus evil yung Drago gonna be the
villain of the film I don't think that
anybody can trash talk so it seems like
what happens is is like in the wake of
the fight during the first film like he
goes through a couple of bouts then it's
some big public match when he's riding
high
Drago's son walks out challenges him
publicly and it gets captured on YouTube
or something like that
the entire world sees it and it just
becomes this compelling underdog story
like oh my god this is gonna be so
amazing so of course he has to accept
it'll be fun to see what other Rocky 3
rocky 4 Easter eggs they have in this
but I haven't read too much about Dolph
Lundgren's arc during the film I don't
know if he has any on-screen reunions
with Sylvester Stallone it would
actually be really cool if they did a
version of the Rocky 3 ending with the
older versions of the characters like
you have rocky step into the ring with
the old Drago training montage obviously
a staple of the Rocky movies you see a
little bit of Adonis doing what looks
like his upgraded training montage
because now he's riding high so he has
the awesome gym so there's just a lot of
funny familiar moments from Rocky for
Drago Sun is the one that's running
through snowdrifts and training and the
really low-rent gym while you have
Adonis who has all the money training in
the really nice gym
[Music]
but just let me know what you think of
this obviously the movie is dropping at
Thanksgiving so I'll totally do a review
when it drops but the big Marvel stuff
that I mentioned in the beginning of the
video is the Disney finally countered
Comcast's offer so it looks like the
Disney Fox deal will eventually go
through they have a meeting that was
originally scheduled to take place in
early July
but then Comcast came in with their big
cash offer and people are like wait a
minute is Comcast gonna buy Fox now Fox
has released a statement saying that
they prefer Disney's new offer so unless
something crazy happens in the next week
or so it just sounds like this Disney
Fox deal is gonna go through but
remember they originally said that they
didn't expect that to be completed till
the end of next summer
like when Kevin Feige would actually be
able to use x-men characters so what'll
happen is is there was a bunch of new
Avenger stuff that drops so I'll do a
video for that later today there's a
whole bunch of stuff going on so I'll
try to post video updates in the commets
so just check my top pin comment on this
video down below for the videos that I'm
working on next but just leave all your
requests in the comments below well you
wait for everything click here for brand
new ant-man and the wasp and click here
for Black Panther bloopers if you
haven't seen them yet thank you so much
for watching everybody stay awesome I'll
see you guys tonight
[Music]